Michael here to walk you through the
details and tech specs of Microsoft's
project Scorpio that finally surfaced
from what we can tell it's going to be
the most powerful console to date but we
won't be able to experience this for
ourselves until around holiday season in
q4 this year when Scorpio releases I'll
walk you through what we know so far if
you'd like to know more about scorpio
check out our initial impressions and
discussion video on our channel so in
honor of confirming the consoles six
sweet teraflops here are six things you
need to know about project scorpio
scorpio six teraflops confirmed first
off a teraflop is simply a measurement
of performance though not a perfect
indicator of how games will run it gives
us an idea of where it'll stand among
the other consoles and comparable PC
components how does scorpio six
teraflops stack up against the
competition well for starters this
measures out about four and a half times
higher than the xbox one compared to
sony's ps4 this is roughly a 30 percent
increase Scorpio will be a graphical
power house among consoles the GPU
itself is comprised of 40 custom compute
units clocked at 1172 megahertz for a
console it's fast cpu and system on chip
design Scorpios horsepower is built into
what's called a system-on-chip or SOC
both the graphics and central processing
units are housed on the SOC which is
where you'll find the eight core cpu
it's described as an evolved version of
the jaguar bass cpus seen in the xbox
one and it's clock that two point three
gigahertz for scorpio 550 megahertz
faster than the xbox one like the ps4
ps4 pro and Xbox one Scorpios SOC is
made by AMD more memory 12 gigabytes of
gddr5 ram microsoft built 12 gigabytes
of gddr5 system memory into scorpio as
it stands 8 gigabytes will be dedicated
to games while 4 gigabytes will focus on
background processes and overhead this
is a sizable upgrade from xbox one
slower ddr3 RAM and 8 gigabytes overall
with only 5 gigabytes dedicated to games
is this important from what we can tell
yes the system was shown using a little
bit over 5 gigabytes in the floors the
demo used to show off Scorpios power
Forza demo native 4k speaking of Forza
alongside the reveal of its tech specs
Scorpio was shown running the Forza tech
engine used in Forza Motorsport 6 and
horizon 3 the demo was set to be a
straight port from the xbox one but with
native 4k resolution and high res art
assets Anna was pushing out 60 frames
per second with room to spare according
to the benchmark from digital foundry
the system peaked at about seventy
percent GPU usage texture filtering
lighting shadows remain untouched when
pushing the PC equivalent of ultra
settings the game still ran at 60 frames
per second with eighty eight percent GPU
usage keep in mind that this is one
scenario and scorpios performance will
vary from game to game true 4k was
promised and as far as we can tell it's
being delivered but not every game may
hit 60 frames per second regardless this
is impressive backwards compatibility if
you have your eyes set on project
Scorpio but you're worried about certain
games not running on it don't trip every
Xbox one game will work just fine on
Scorpio and every xbox 360 backwards
compatible game will as well if games
are to take advantage of the improved
hardware the onus is on the software
side more powerful than the ps4 pro yes
project Scorpio is more powerful than
the ps4 pro which was to be expected
however both the pro and Scorpio
required developers to implement changes
to take advantage of the more powerful
hardware it's hard to say how difficult
this will be for developers but games
that render at 1080p and even 900p are
said to have native 4k support with
Scorpio it remains to be seen what if
any graphical compromises need to be
made to maintain stable performance in
future games there it is the details we
have so far on Microsoft's project
Scorpio did the news turn your head what
other details do you want to see from
Microsoft hit up those comments I know
you liked this video so show some love
with that like button and to keep up
with future details of Scorpio subscribe
to our channel here at gamespot
you